[Music]
sometimes a player's greatest opponent
isn't another player
it isn't criticism you're gonna go into
the post match third and you're gonna
write Wow oh gee is so good but I still
don't think honest a very good mid
player it isn't some decade-old curse or
an army of incredible teams I think it's
safe to say or fair to say that eg are
the favorites going into this
they looked super good in the group
stage they looked really convincing in
there first off the bracket match
sometimes a players greatest opponent is
themselves when I first started it was
really hard I think it was experience
like even in life I didn't know myself
for a long time people thought that
anathan on a fom was one of the most
overrated players in dota a
self-conscious 16 year old who didn't
have the mental fortitude to cut it in
the big leagues even though he played
for one of the biggest teams in the
world
those people were wrong now he's a
two-time major winner one of the only
players to ever win back-to-back ti and
as far as the community is concerned the
undisputable god of dota but he didn't
just have to beat the best teams in the
world to make history he had to beat
himself
[Music]
so how did on ago from a villainized
prodigy to basically the most successful
player to ever touch of the game well it
all started in 2016 back then Anna was a
shy Australian pub star who made a name
for himself climbing dota 2's ranked
lattic but the thing that stood out
about him from the get-go was his play
style
unlike sumail and miracles he wasn't
allowed confident and flashy on the
contrary he was quiet cerebral and
unpredictable I reckon Nathan's always
being shy that's what I think that's how
he gets away with being sneaky you never
show if you he's the entire hand he
always has something hidden or up his
sleeve it allows him to have an
advantage that you don't know still he
caught the attention of Invictus gaming
who asked him in March to be a
substitute for their legendary mid laner
Ferrari 430 eventually IgE came forward
was like hey do you want to give it a
shot with us you know it's any boy's
dream so when the opportunity comes out
for your brother can't help but say do
it all no one is first land just a few
months later in July his entrance into
the pro scene had been kind of low-key
but he'd caught the attention of the
international community and everyone was
wondering the same thing
who the hell was this guy I remember
like one of the first comments I saw was
just like Ana I thought it was a girl
like everyone thought it was a girl I
thought that it was just funny noise
like nah he's my brother he's a guy but
one team was particularly interesting in
autumn oh gee TI o j1 in me Vidya was
like one of the best in the world I
thought it would be like too much of a
leap but that's the reason why I learned
the most here because everything was
like a massive leaf the pickup was a bit
of a surprise Oh G had won two majors
during their 2016-2017 season and after
bombing out of TI lost their star
midlaner miracle so picking up a player
is unknown as Anna seemed risky it was
kind of a risk in a way but from my
perspective first conversation with Anna
Anna said let's go win some majors and
there was an S there you know so one was
not enough there is that insane
confidence in him
let's go win some majors that said og
had developed a reputation for winning
majors and let's just say that signing
on ax didn't exactly buck that trend
[Applause]
it's an incredible thing
[Applause]
major winners here energy you would
think with that celebration it was the
first time they wanna major the problem
is that Anna was inconsistent oftentimes
it didn't feel like oh gee winning
because of him but rather in spite of
him and now jaracz is here for the
rotation jabs in a very unfortunate
situation he is going to die for sure
that mild step back unfortunately he'll
try to go through the fairy fire it's
always a regardless right in the face of
Anna he'll say worth see Anna was the
kind of player who let his emotions get
the better of them peak story like if I
said oh it's really frustrating yes like
I can't play no hockey because they're
heroes that are very passive like we let
them dictate the pace of the game and it
doesn't figure the sign of Nick there's
been a fire but sometimes he'd
single-handedly carry o G to victory he
is major bran I showed Mike what kind of
a player he is he doesn't really think
of the things that can go bad he thinks
about what he can do and then he goes
for it no hesitation I'm just gonna run
in and [ __ ]
that is the best way to play them I'm
not he had it inside him
other times he spelled disaster for the
team and then a TI seven it all came
crashing down after an insane season Oh
G plays seventh eighth in a tournament
they were supposed to win and onna
announced that he was taking a break
from competitive dota after TI 7 there
was a bit of fatigue especially in
tanana
people can get really really harsh even
tours on a 17 year old boy that is
thousands of miles away from home
and it happens very often in DotA and
that's what it was with Anna I mean he
was getting a lot of flack the whole
players they just break because of it
and then Anna just kind of disappeared
occasionally he'd pop up in some random
stack at some qualifier but the general
consensus was that he'd retired that the
stakes had been too high and he was too
fragile it's just one to one of it but
you screw it up once and I think it's
gone it's a lot of pressure and I didn't
really enjoy that pressure and then in
May 2018 fly and s4 ditched a declining
og for Evil Geniuses after acquiring
Thompson oh gee had just one month to
find a new carry player the issue was
that all the top-tier choices were
already on top tier teams well all
except for what the next logical choice
for us was Anna Anna hadn't played for a
long time we knew honor don't we knew
how powerful he was as a player Anna
coming back I mean people at that point
were like probably the last person still
available sure why not with on a back on
the team oh geez Cinderella their way
through TI 8 and it quickly became clear
that something within him had changed
make a mistake
anna was still the same nervous
self-conscious guy he'd always been but
this time it wasn't affecting his
performance could start to feel
buildin here for oh geez in previous
year at ti7 seem like Hana he was the
one that was playing inconsistently not
doing it in undisputed and now all of a
sudden people started looking back and
being like maybe onna was the magic to
their team in a meadow where Kerry
players were struggling to perform Hana
didn't just excel
he played out of his [ __ ] mind these
saves are just so crazy how come they
didn't go down they became even when
talked to who ticks down to nine seconds
now but these save just back and forth
via from the cold embrace even the curse
to protecting become substitutions that
right there the overclocked look at
honor
it looks like he's is dead in the
stuccis over another now as you said the
combination living armor saving it for
this first few rainbows coming in from
chalice and then the cold embrace they
just couldn't kill him off their
confident knowing Sam can sit there on
the high ground ready with the
counterplay army getting sprouted
chalice looks to make a blade Johnson
immediately going for it with the lasso
has he got the control to get the damage
idk if that's gonna be on a dead banana
buys back straightaway army moving in
with a BKB rochette still alive
throughout this or never lost Thompson
the slightly changed the railroad across
don't get the kill to Japanese in the
middle using himself what the flame
guard ticking up for now on the son of
theirs
as og they fight three they look to us
of the surrounding and in the pits of
this he'll go down as welcome as
securing that by air for OG o the army
just on the tip ultimate but it's not
enough to buy tactical own wares are
they there with the general Bastas under
on Tehran is able to rent him out to the
side chalice hiding in the trees
thompson starting throughout the
Lightning is armed a chalice backing
away skewer forward 470 clears out the
trees chalice still with a firefly
getting himself away will jump himself
away from the Nimbus backs himself up
makes no it's got to be careful he's
incredibly low they're looking a set of
Avatar and army his miss grounded the
stolen Fisher for jerks power to our
Weber they're pointing with the slab is
it or not no and stop LGD that belongs
to yet again but they have managed to
fight to in return and is still alive
the flame guard keep it in fight again
the side
cuts down a second double kill ferrata
Charley's surrounded by seven on a hare
in the trees
[Applause]
the genes life two months after
rejoining og Hana was seen is a huge
part of the craziest he I win the dota
world had ever seen
oh gee congratulations to to og they
deserved it
[Applause]
and follow anyone else strategy maybe
that was
they just played the wrong game anyways
a miraculous but the journey has been
long tiresome and stressful and just as
quickly as he'd arrived he was gone when
I first talked on I was to early 2017 I
believe and I hit the first sentence or
lacked lessons before he joined the team
was let's let's win some majors and the
TI and it was kinda what was missing so
hired was accepted he did it and I was
out of stone so you asked for this over
the next few months
Oh G tried out carry player after carry
player but some of them stuck and they
went back to being that same uninspired
roster they were before they're faded
win the TI and then in March
Oh G announced and Anna was back on the
active roster the community immediately
started meaning that with on a back in
the lineup the stars had finally aligned
for og to be the first ever repeat TI
champion so why is it that winning to
TI's has been so difficult thus far well
it hasn't been that difficult for us so
far we're not day
[Laughter]
but even with the return of onna og
still seems pretty medium they finished
10th on the dota pro circuit which meant
that they had enough points to qualify
for TI 9 but nobody really expected much
of them what's the group-stage world
around
what happened next though shocked the
dota world to its core
even infamous isn't waiting that they
like carried whoa what the what is HAP
is this a carry acts have we been dude
I'm ready
I want carry act so oh they're doing
what is the card for to okay so I'm
already wrong sad I know tell all right
oh he gets routed so we can't even get
on top of anyone Steph just gets his BKB
up oh jeez just cutting around
everywhere ace has to run away to the
it's too much the ANA they're just going
into there they can't use our all to
spread what can you do give someone a
rampage I don't think they can they're
going into the bauen they're waiting for
an IV to call GG but they won't and Luth
as they go in I don't know what the
triple kill honor with an ultra kill
there's a sand king where is he they
know the IO doesn't have ulti to come
get him though it looks like they'll
just gonna end the game here and there's
the GG's call on the back of honest
carry with OD finished thirteen and one
in groups then steamrolled their way to
the International grand finals for the
second year in a row the difference was
that this year they didn't seem to take
any part of it seriously nothing is
really going here and talk to this guy
to the mountain funds again bathe in the
glory of the radiant Thompson he does
does not give a crap Anna will give all
the life this is just better than
bombing breaking JJ it is booking spice
approach here right now that is true
their landing stage I was skeptical on
the start especially about this bottom
lane but things are looking great right
now
mainly because our teeth Daisy Khan
cross at top lane except in real trouble
in the middle of a call down the
attendance will not help him
the harming missile from Samoa will wipe
that smile of his face while flight
under the tier 2 Tower gr accent talks
at once again come Boeing together than
the smash brothers right now s4 as well
as rted the TP
the Jericho
and somehow hana seems completely
unaffected by the pressure sometimes a
little too unaffected he'll be Anna go
claim the life is a double kill again
spy light-eyed and Saif he knows on
looking birds aren't fine everyone's
happy there aren't engagements see C&C
trying to bring down said it won't be
enough third that yo scepter off my bad
indeed excuse to it right-side up it's
easy and see that she gonna claim that
life at t i8 unapproved that he had what
it took to be a champion come to i9
though he just lost all reservations
about playing
[Music]
they're just giving the look at this
they're diving pound and TI final they
want her up the in the baptismal they're
gonna get it they're chasing bears nose
bump oh my god I can't believe this
I got me what was saying in this game
[Applause]
despite all the memeing chat wheeling
and fountain farming on emerge from ti9
is arguably the greatest dota player
ever
and now between the announcement of OGIS
post TI break and a cryptic tweet from
no-tail it remains to be seen what anna
will do next it's not a break for sick
like there should be an offseason and
Zola there should be fine for us to
appreciate those two this achieved you
know rebuild wreak repair the fire when
I went yeah if we start grinding right
away you know we're gonna be burnout we
would lose yet an Artemis 20 I tell you
know our aim is to like keep to keep
point keep building despite the fact
that anna has been a professional dota
player for just over three years
he's only actually played for about a
year and a half in that time he's won
two majors to TI's retired twice if not
three times and accrued just over six
million dollars in prize winnings he is
in no uncertain terms one of the most
successful competitors in any eSport
ever they they did it and now I'm still
scared of them yeah I don't think
they're going anywhere why would you
write well ama is getting on vacation oh
yeah dude could take 11 and a half
months off come back a couple of weeks
before TI cruise into the group stages
and they'd be fine like he's a machine
the Chinese community have literally
dubbed him the god of dota not the a god
or the onna God they placed him above
every other place she's incredibly
penances and like I had merit of twenty
thousand for the game and I truly am it
merited with all of my teammates really
everything they do with this game and
even if he doesn't return to og he will
go down and dota history as a legend a
player who conquered the greatest
obstacle of all himself becomes a best
of course if Anna does emerge from the
myths of fates and rejoin og they'll
probably win ti for a third time at
which point the community will probably
start a religion in his name or
something God knows I join
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages